The Olympics in Rio were supposed to be a
coming out party for Brazil, to showcase the
South American giant, 150 million people,
economic powerhouse, energy powerhouse.
Unfortunately, the reality has changed in
that country in the recent years, slipped
into a recession, demonstrations among anxious
Brazilians, literally running Dilma Rousseff,
the president, out of office.
For the athletes gathering in Rio, they expect
fair competition.
They expect even-handed judges.
Unfortunately, for Brazilians, that's not
the reality, they have had to deal with a
state that has an oppressive presence in their
lives.
It picks winners and losers, it over-taxes
them, it makes it harder for them to do business,
to create jobs.
And Michel Temer, the interim president, has
an opportunity to change that, to bring in
competition into the system, more capital,
create jobs, and create a better future for
the Brazilian people.
If he can achieve that, the Brazilian people
can achieve a victory of Olympic proportions.
Do you think these Olympic Games will be a
turning point for Brazil or will it be more
of the same?
Please share your comments and give us your
ideas on other topics that you'd like AEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds.